bonjour bienvenue merci
dans les instructions on a besoin de
d'une diversité de représentation comme
la population française et on a aussi
des profils divers de Français installés
à l'étranger qui font plein de choses
différentes et donc c'est aussi
important que qu'il soit représenté
la cocarde l'écharpe tricolores et enfin
un signe je suis engagée chez les
écologistes et donc c'est important pour
moi que de pouvoir représenter cette
génération et les enjeux de cette
génération au Sénat face à l'anxiété
climatique d'une partie de la génération
serait amener à prendre la parole soit
sur les micros qui sont dans les travées
ou bien la tribune de l'orateur juste
ici
j'étais déjà venue mais
là maintenant ça prend une autre
signification
on se rend bien compte que beaucoup de
choses peuvent se passer au local il
faut bien sûr des impulsions des
impulsions nationales européennes
internationales mais il y a aussi
beaucoup d'initiatives qui commencent et
qui se développent localement ce sera
beaucoup les villes qui auront à
s'adapter où les territoires qui auront
à s'adapter à changement climatique ces
prochaines années ou c'est aussi
important de les accompagner
[Musique]